this is just genuinely terrible news the
state of New York has decided to cancel
the Democratic presidential primary
which they had rescheduled to June 23rd
because of coronavirus and you might be
wondering why is it terrible either way
Joe Biden is going to be the Democratic
nominee it has everything to do with
Donald Trump
we already suspect that Donald Trump is
likely to try funny business in November
we don't know exactly what the funny
business will be but there are a number
of different things that he is likely to
try
why would Democrats do anything that
could be seen as any kind of precedent
for funny business in November and I
know many of you will say listen David
canceling a primary when there is only
one candidate remaining is very
different than canceling or postponing a
highly contested presidential election
and you would be correct that they are
not the same thing
but this is Donald Trump that we're
talking about Donald Trump who's already
been playing up that the Democrats are
stealing it from Bernie Sanders Donald
Trump who complains to this day about an
election that he won he says the results
were wrong he won in 2016 electorally so
this is something that could only
embolden Trump in opposing vote-by-mail
in November in who knows what other
ideas Trump might have and would be
emboldened and now Trump can say listen
everything's different this time around
look at what Democrats did in New York
what New York should have done is say
we're going to do the election 100% by
mail it'll be a 100 percent absentee
ballot election there are two months to
set this up - a few days this can be
done it would help to make the case that
the election in November must go on but
by mail so New York is doing the exact
opposite of what they should be doing
New York could foment the case for vote
by mail in November by doing it
themselves and saying look we said it we
did it we set it up we're not normally a
vote by mail state but we were able to
do it instead they are cancelling an
election altogether and you're doing two
things when you do this number one you
are enraging the Bernie or Busters and
there's something to be said about that
although the
agree to which this will impact whether
they ultimately vote for Joe Biden in
November I don't know but number two
you're giving Trump something to point
to if he ends up saying hey let's delay
the November election that's it Trump
can't do that unilaterally remember it's
up to States to delay or not delay
elections but Trump could say please do
it or you give Trump the opportunity to
push against vote-by-mail by saying
listen if it were so easy and logical to
do vote by mail
why didn't New York do it they canceled
the primary clearly vote by mail isn't
that easy to do so these are all very
good questions and it all gives Trump
cover for funny business now I know some
of you are going to write to me and
you're going to say
many states canceled Republican
primaries over the virus the point is
Trump can't really use that in November
to try to pull funny business a
Democratic primary being canceled
altogether opens the door to be misused
and abused by Donald Trump now here's
the crazy thing there are still going to
be down ballot elections in New York on
June 23rd according to the New York
Times polling places are expected to
remain open in in 42 counties in New
York State
four down ballot races and you will be
able to obtain absentee ballots to vote
in those so much of New York State is
still having an election on June 23rd
but they've eliminated the Democratic
primary obviously Biden was going to win
the New York Democratic primary
obviously the outcome of the primary
overall was not going to change with or
without New York voting but you're still
holding an election for other down
ballot races and you are giving Trump
something he can potentially use I think
it's a very bad idea I think this is the
wrong decision being made by New York if
you disagree with me let me know what if
you could read ten books in just one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for there's
a full book you're thinking about buying
you can use blankets to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself by being able to soak up an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video